this is what home looks like for 200,000
foreign workers who live in government
licensed dormitories migrants account
for 85% of all kovat 19 cases here al
Jazeera spoke on the phone to a migrant
worker living in one of the dormitories
he asked not to be identified for fear
of being sacked he's tested negative but
still worries about contracting the
virus an academic in New Zealand who's
done research on migrant workers in
Singapore says the inability to maintain
physical distancing can cause a workers
health to suffer all the kinds of
behaviors they need to practice it is
simply that structure they are unable to
practice those behaviors there is a
great deal of anxiety and fear that the
workers express thousands of healthy or
recovered workers have been moved to
floating hotels or military barracks to
curb the spread of the coronavirus the
Singapore government which already has
one of the highest testing rates in the
world is planning to boost its capacity
to 40,000 tests a day the manpower
minister has promised to improve the
dormitories as soon as the virus crisis
eases but a migrant workers rights group
says living conditions are a sign of a
much bigger problem working among us we
don't expect that they enjoy the same
housing conditions as we do as in the
polls but also we don't expect them to
enjoy the same salaries as for the same
work we don't expect them to have the
same access to medical care that we as
citizens do and although this makes the
problem worse
he says workers are often penalised
my employers for being absent which
could have deterred some from seeking
medical attention about 20% of
Singapore's population are foreign
workers they're in relatively low paying
jobs such as construction and
manufacturing the city-state
doesn't have a minimum wage activists
say the government not only needs to
re-examine its reliance on cheap
imported labor but also the level of
protection workers have Florence lui al
Jazeera